can we talk about the mind of Vladimir
Putin you've mentioned that this idea
that he has aspirations
for uh imperialist
Conquest that he dreams of Empire is not
grounded in reality he wrote an essay in
2021 about one
people do you think there is some degree
to
which he still dreams of the former
Soviet Union
reuniting no he's made it clear that uh
anybody with a a triple digigit IQ
understands that it's nuts to think
about recreating the Soviet
Union he thinks it's a tragedy that the
Soviet Union fell apart but as he made
clear in that essay the July 12th 2021
essay and has he made clear in speeches
before immediately before he inv invaded
Ukraine he
accepted uh the breakup of the Soviet
Union and he accepted uh the status quo
in in Europe safe for the fact he did
not accept the idea that Ukraine would
become part of NATO he's been in power
for over two decades is there a degree
that power can
affect a Leader's ability to see the
world
clearly as they say
corrupt um do you think power has
corrupted Vladimir Putin to a degree
it's very hard for me to answer that
question because I don't know him and
I've not studied him carefully uh in
terms of his overall performance over
the course of you know the 23 years that
he's been in
power uh I've studied him as a
strategist and I've studied how he you
know deals with the West uh and you know
deals with the International System more
generally uh since
2014 and I think he is a first class
strategist this is not to say he doesn't
make
mistakes uh and he admits he's made some
mistakes uh U but uh I think that the
West is dealing with a formidable
adversary here uh and I don't see any
evidence that he's either lost speed off
his fast ball or that power has
corrupted his thinking about strategic
Affairs so he has consistently put as a
primary concern
security as does the United States he's
put for Russia security making sure that
NATO doesn't get close to its borders I
think that's clear yeah I I think is I
emphasized early on in our conversation
that leaders privilege security or
survival over everything else and by the
way he gave a number of talks uh and
press
conferences uh in addition to writing
that famous article that you referred to
on July 12 2021 so we have you know a
pretty clear record of what he was
saying and I would argue what he was
thinking in the runup to the war in
February
2022 and if you read uh what he said uh
it's quite clear that he privileged
security or survival he was deeply
concerned about the security of Russia
and Russia is a quite vulnerable state
in a lot of ways especially if you think
back to what it looked like in the 1990s
is you know better than I do uh it was
in terrible shape uh the Chinese talk
about the century of national
humiliation one could argue that for the
Russians that was the decade of national
humiliation and um and it took Putin I
think quite a bit of time to bring the
Russians back from the dead I think he
eventually succeeded but uh it took a
considerable amount of time and I think
he understood that he was not playing a
particularly strong hand he was playing
something of a weak hand and he had to
be very careful very cautious and I
think was uh and I think that's very
different than the United States the
United States was the unipole it was the
most powerful state in the history of
the world most powerful State relative
to all its possible competitors from you
know roughly 1989 certainly after
December 1991 when the Soviet Union fell
apart up until I would argue about 2017
we were incredibly powerful and even
after
2017 up to today the United States
Remains the most powerful state in the
system and because of our geographical
location uh we are in a uh
terrific uh situation to survive in any
great power competition so uh you have a
situation involving the United States
that's different than the situation
involving Russia they're they're just
much more vulnerable uh than we are and
and therefore I think Putin tends to be
more sensitive about security uh than
any American president in recent Times
Europe on one side China on the other
side it's a complicated situation yeah
and we talked before about 1812 when
Napoleon invaded and Moscow got burned
to the ground we talked about World War
I where the Russians were actually
defeated uh and surrendered uh and then
we talked about 1941 to 1945 where
although thankfully
uh the Soviets prevailed uh it was uh it
was a close call and I mean the
casualties the destruction that the
Soviet
Union uh had inflicted on it by the
Germans is just almost almost hard to
believe
just uh so they are sensitive you can
understand full well or at least you
should be able to understand full well
why the idea of bringing Ukraine up to
their border really spooked them uh I
don't understand why more Americans
don't understand that it just it it
befuddles me I think it has to do with
the fact that Americans are not very
good in putting themselves in the shoes
of other countries uh and uh you really
if if you're going to be a first class
strategist in international politics you
have to be able to do that you have to
put yourself in the shoes of the other
side and think about how they think so
you don't make foolish mistakes and as a
starting point Americans tend to see
themselves as the good guys and a set of
others as the bad guys and you have to
be able to empathize that Russians think
of themselves as the good guys the
Chinese think of themselves as the good
guys and just be able to empathize if
they are the good guys it's like that uh
funny skit are we the baddies consider
the United States could be the bad guys
like first of all EMP like
see the world if the United States is
the bad guys and China is the good guys
what does that world look like be able
to just exist with that thought because
that is what the Chinese leadership and
many Chinese citizens uh if not now
maybe in the future we believe and you
have to kind of do the calculation the
simulation forward from that and same
with Russia same with with other nations
yeah I agree with you 100% and just you
know I always think of of Michael McFall
Stanford who was the American ambassador
to uh Russia I think between 2012 and
2014 and uh he told me that he told
Putin uh that Putin didn't have to worry
about NATO expansion because the United
States was a benign hegemon and uh I
asked Mike what Putin's response was to
that and uh Mike said Putin didn't
believe it uh and uh but Mike believed
that he should believe it and that we
could move NATO Eastward to include
Ukraine and in the end we' get away with
it because we are a benign hon but the
fact is that's not what Putin saw Putin
saw us as a mign hedgemon and what Mike
thinks or any American thinks doesn't
matter what matters is what Putin thinks
but also the drums of War have been
beating for some reason NATO expansion
has been threatened for some reason so
you've talked about NATO expansion being
dead so like it doesn't make sense from
a geop political perspective on the
Europe side to expand NATO uh but
nevertheless that threat has been uh
echoed so um why has NATO expansion been
pushed from your perspective
there two reasons one is first of all we
thought it was a wonderful thing uh to
bring more and more countries into NATO
we thought that it facilitated peace and
prosperity it was ultimately all for the
good um and uh we also thought that uh
uh countries like Ukraine had a right to
join NATO these are sovereign countries
that can decide for themselves and the
Russians have no say in what Ukraine
wants to do and then finally and uh this
is a point I emphasized before we were
very powerful and we thought we could
shove it down their throat so so it's a
combination of those factors that led us
to pursue what I think was ultimately uh
a foolish
policy
that